en détruisant la nature l'humanité se
retrouve au bord du précipice
[Musique]
il s'est peut être la seule grande
organisation russie qui s'occupe de la
protection des espèces menacées
ce projet c'est avant tout la
restauration du patrimoine génétique
danny faure ce n'est pas seulement un
prédateur c'est un indicateur de l'état
de l'environnement dans lequel nous
vivons
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on fait le maçon détruit la
tête
on y laisse de profondes blessures je
t'aime on croit être le maître de la
terre
[Musique]
l'activité humaine est à l'origine de la
sixième extinction de masse mais les
héros de notre film ne peuvent s'y
résoudre
[Musique]
en raison de la rapide fonte des glaces
en arctique les morses et leurs
compagnons éternel des ours polaires
sont obligés de vivre de plus en plus
proche des hommes aujourd'hui un ours
polaire est passé c'était un jeune il
n'a peur de rien on dit qu'il était
assis en face du club les gars qui l'ont
vu l'ont fait fuir en criant
[Musique]
tiens on se dirige maintenant vers le
cap koschevnikov kinshasa va aller nos
ancêtres l'appeler ouvrir karpine parce
qu'il ya toujours beaucoup de morceaux
tatiana mininko fait partie de la
patrouille des ours
elle va vérifier si les morses ont pu
atteindre le cap koschevnikov sur le cap
les ours affamé les espionnes déjà
tatiana n'utilise pas d'armes
tout ce qu'elle a sur elle c'est un
javelot que lui a offert son mari est
dans les situations les plus critiques
elle peut utiliser une fusée
c'est matt j'envoie 17
[Musique]
voilà là ils sont au complet
j'espère qu'on colis traités avec autant
d'ours les morses peuvent ne pas sortir
du tout et si les morses ne sortent pas
ici cette année les ours passeront par
le village en migrant
une vieille femelle morse est seul sur
la rive le troupeau ne permet pas aux
animaux malades de s'approcher
elle se prépare donc à mourir seul le
cap koschevnikov est en russie l'un des
deux endroits où les morses s'échoue
pour mourir
[Musique]
il y à un mois on a apporté ici 40
carcasse de maurs les restes qui se
trouvait sur le littoral du village
pourquoi ici de là on voit bien les ours
c'est à dire qu'on peut les contrôler
[Musique]
c'est ma lisette bébé mort ce là il y en
a deux l'un est plus grand et l'autre à
des défenses petit comme ça c'est un ado
voilà je compte déjà les morts le festin
de l'ours polaire a commencé ils ne
s'approchent pas des morses dans l'eau à
ce qu'ils peuvent les frapper avec leur
défense
un bébé vous sur le littoral ils ont une
tactique qui consiste à repousser les
troupeaux à le faire entrer dans la mer
enfin de tuer des bébés morts
voilà il a pris le corps d'un tout petit
morceau
sur désolé on s'en va
courtoisie mange tranquillement
pour moi ce lieu à beaucoup d'importance
c'est un droit qui met vraiment précieux
parce que c'est ici que mes ancêtres
vivaient
c'est juste oui c'est notre terrano ici
se trouve la ire en gadoue en arrière
grand père et deux en arrière grand mère
chaque campement nomade à son chef fera
et sa maison est le principal endroit où
se rencontrent n est l ouest
tatiana a du sens des touches de la
toundra et des côtes mais aussi du sang
ukrainiens par son arrière grand père
ivan milenko il a voyagé dans différents
pays mais c'est ici au bout du monde
qu'il a trouvé sa place et son amour il
y avait seulement deux endroits où les
gens étaient particulièrement obstiné
qui aurait elle ne voulait pas accepter
le pouvoir soviétique billing et notre
rire capitaux quand ils ont appris que
mon arrière grand père evans mininko
était partisan match ils vont rater ils
ont voulu le chasser ou le tuer
il a dû accepter de coopérer avec eux et
était directeur d'un élevage de fourrure
il considérait déjà cette terre comme sa
patrie il avait déjà des enfants ici on
ans il a appris à vivre ici il est
devenu un vrai tchouktche zhu signifier
ouvrait grave qui signifie homme c'est à
dire un vrai
il y en a beaucoup quand on en a besoin
il faut marcher chercher longtemps on
vous sert à chaque poil sur lequel on
tombe et là vous pourrez tricoter un
gilet avec tout ça
l'analyse des poils permet de déterminer
de quelle source il s'agit ici et s'il
se rend fréquemment sur les mêmes
territoires
je veux que les décomptes soit faible
par exemple
même chez nous on dit que si 20 hours
plus se rassemblent même endroit c'est
qu'il est temps de les chasser
noftall comme beaucoup ils sont trop
nombreux on tente d'expliquer aux gens
que les animaux se rassemblent ici non
pas parce qu'ils aiment ces lieux mais
parce qu'ils sont désespérés à cause de
la catastrophique fonte des glaces et en
reste très peu et nous voyons ici que le
niveau de la mer monte
la côte s'enfonce lentement sous les
eaux pauvres
[Musique]
c'est un grand groupe à rostov
une véritable île de moeurs
ils ont peur de sortir sur les rivages
ils s'entassent dans l'eau
[Musique]
ah ils sont sortis
regardez regardez un os ce mal n'a
aucune intention de s'enfuir on dirait
que notre équipe de tournage ne semble
pas représenter pour lui une menace
sérieuse et qu'il est prêt à défendre
son territoire
la première fusée est partie des mains
de tatiana après un moment d'hésitation
l'ours décide d'attaquer
[Musique]
où
c'est une longue descente
vous n'avez pas peur que vous avez vu
comment les cris peuvent aider rayé ça
marche bien oui ouais voilà voilà c'est
comme ça
comme si vos greniers oui c'est ça voilà
comme ça il faut prendre un bâton et
s'il ya une surface à proximité taper
sur cette surface afin de faire du bruit
plus et former ses salariés aussi fort
que vous pouvez ça y est si vous voyez
qu'il ya un danger un ours qui est
entrée dans le village par exemple il ya
partout des annonces avec nos numéros de
téléphone
on se charge de protéger les gens et de
protéger les ours aussi pour éviter que
les gens ne les tue ça marche dans les
deux sens on se trouve entre le marteau
et l'enclume en gros ma part merci au
fond rêviez-vous de faire partie de la
patrouille des ours ça tony blair non
j'avais beaucoup de rêves différents en
fait mais ça a été toujours quelque part
au fond de moi on m'a d'abord demandé
d'aidé avec les morses
puis avec les ours et j'ai réalisé que
c'était ma vocation
il n'avait même pas me demander
en 2006 lorsque les morts sont sortis
spontanément il y en avait plus de 50000
la population lequel les étourdis c'est
avec des haches là où il a échoué
c'est bon ce n'est pas par année on peut
le retirer leur défense
je l'est surveillé depuis le rivage puis
les volontaires se sont organisés et
prenez des tours de garde d'une heure en
2007 les gens de wwf m'ont demandé de
surveiller les ours et les boks bonjour
tatiana s'est engagé dans la lutte
contre le braconnage par vocation mais
pour gagner sa vie elle est obligée de
travailler comme concierge est femme de
ménage
bon alors le chien reste à faire un top
il ya des plumes par payer partout sur
l'escalier je vais pas nettoyé après toi
je laisse des propriétaires faire ça
encore mais comment on peut laisser
faire ça je te dis je ne vais pas
nettoyé et je nettoie tout de même
d'autres cas on dira qu'on me paie pour
ça mais pour de telles choses
certainement pas j'en ai encore cinq
maisons à faire pas tant et puis j'ai un
autre travail de concierge à temps
partiel parfois je balaie les escaliers
parfois les cours n voilà et nous on
parle dans notre nettoyage sur le
littoral sur la côte cassée mais non
nabil et recours d'attac ou et les gens
ne veulent même pas nettoyé après eux
mêmes
[Musique]
jacopo chase ni comme personne ne s'en
soucie
il serait agréable de se promener le
long d'une côte propres il devrait y
avoir un vrai patron quelqu'un qui prend
à coeur tout ce qui l'entourait sur son
contenu
[Musique]
je vais
alors petit bonhomme je n'ai que des
petites filles quatre petites filles
c'est le premier garçon la vie de
tatiana aurait pu être tout à fait
différente
elle a été élevée dans une pension on
l'a préparé pour l'école supérieure des
beaux-arts de leningrad
mais elle aspirait à retourner dans la
toundra chez sa mère sur sa terre natale
aujourd'hui à la cinq enfants et cinq
petits enfants elle et son mari
patrouille et elle ne s'imagine pas
vivre ailleurs
[Musique]
pendant la nuit les morts sont à nouveau
tenter de sortir sur le littoral mais
cette fois ci ils ont été effrayés par
des intrus vous voyez
vous voyez ce bateau il a enfreint les
règles le cap que jenny kof est en
monuments naturels d'importance
régionale et par conséquent s'acheter la
circulation des bateaux est maintenant
interdite à moins de 2 outre km du cap
ce bateau a effrayé tous les ours qui se
trouvait là du côté ils ont tous sauté
dans le jeu tant chez les bateaux
accélèrent il va plus vite
je n'ai pas peur de nous s'il te plaît
à chaque intrusion des navires dans la
zone frontalière
tatiana fait un rapport au chef du poste
frontière
oui c'est la tâche des gardes-frontières
les terres considéré comme routes
migratoires des espèces menacées doivent
être protégés ils doivent mener des
campagnes de sensibilisation auprès des
gens mais aussi les punir
je n'arrive pas à les joindre par
téléphone
[Musique]
à
l'ours est ses deux oursons ont nagé
assez loin ils sont déjà fatigués je
n'ai pas aller là où se trouvent deux
ours de mal ça c'est parce qu'ils
peuvent les tuer quand ils n'ont rien à
manger
s'il ya une pénurie de nourriture ils
peuvent les tuer ce bateau a fait peur à
tout le monde
[Musique]
oh
et
aujourd'hui tatiana voit son fils cadet
prendre la route de l'école la seule
chose que craint cette femme intrépide
et qu'un jour rires caip deviennent trop
petits pour ses enfants
et pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'image est remarqué qu'ils ont un lien
très fort avec moi
nos ancêtres nos mères et nos pères qui
ne sont plus là sont toujours près de
nous surtout quand on retourne là d'où
on vient où sont nos racines
cet instant on pourrait dire que la fnar
vie ce que ça nous a été donné il faut
en profiter à fond il y en a qui suivent
cette philosophie le décaper gens qui
ont coupé cette forêt n'ont aucun
respect ils vivent avec cette mentalité
ici il y aura un désert les trois cent
prochaines années
un territoire complètement abandonnés ou
sangliers cerfs et chevreuils se
tiendront à l'écart il n'y aura plus de
tigres et si ça ne devrait pas se passer
comme ça
mon chemin vers la protection de la
nature n'a pas été facile j'ai d'abord
choisi la profession d'ingénieur minier
général je travaillais sur une grande
excavatrices qui en une seconde vous
pouvez enlever 15 mètres cubes de sol
aux bourgognes un jour à 6 olivier de
cet énorme excavatrices quand j'ai vu
après avoir démoli de montagne c'est
immense étendue bleue val et je me suis
rendu compte que c'était beaucoup plus
important pour moi que tout ce que je
faisais je suis devenu biologiste
spécialiste de la chasse je ne regrette
absolument pas je fais ce que j'aime je
m'occupe de la protection de la nature
le rhône
je travaille déjà depuis 25 ans pour le
wwf
c'est fou
[Musique]
honnêtement je pense que mes collègues
et moi même avons beaucoup accompli
[Musique]
mais il ya encore beaucoup à faire nous
devons nous assurer de la survie de ce
prédateur dans la nature elle car le
tigre n'est pas seulement un prédateur
aux dents acérées pour affable c'est un
indicateur de l'état de l'environnement
dans lequel nous vivons
en tant qu il ya des tigres tout ira
bien
[Musique]
voilà il est dans ce coin là il s'agit
là d'une opération pour endormir un
tigre afin de procéder à une
intervention chirurgicale au centre de
réhabilitation d'alexei afca un jour
cette procédure ordinaire a pourtant
failli coûter la vie à pavel fomento à
présent on fait un piège classique pour
les tigres intègre dans cette vidéo
pavel n'a pas encore les cicatrices que
lui a infligée la tigresse kazatchkine
qui l'a attaqué ils se cachent
il veut pas se montrer regardez il est
là la vitesse d'un tigre qui attaquent
atteint les 80 kilomètres heure ce jour
là le grillage n'a pas suffi à retenir
la tigresse elle l'a déchiré et à
attaquer pavel en un seul coup elle a
réussi à le frapper à la tête et à
l'épaule gauche
ce n'est qu'après de nombreuses
opérations que pavel a pu retourner au
travail
le soleil se lève sur le centre de
réhabilitation d'alex kfk ce matin nous
avons pris ma bien aimée tigresse
kazakhs cas je veux dire nous l'avons
immobilisé afin de la transporter
aujourd'hui par avion à krasnoïarsk où
elle vivra dans un zoo
heureusement les spécialistes ont réussi
à réhabiliter les deux petits de kasaji
cas et les ont ensuite relâché dans la
nature
contrairement à leur mère ils ont montré
les compétences de chasse approprié pour
des animaux sauvages
kazatchkine elle une fois en liberté
recommencé à attaquer le bétail dans les
villages cela arrive assez souvent en
extrême orient
encore une fois c'est l'homme qui est à
blâmer en détruisant les forêts en chats
sont les proies sauvages
il ne laisse pas d'autre choix aux
prédateurs
[Musique]
c'était très difficile de retourner au
travail parce que eh bien j'ai subi neuf
opérations
c'est psychologiquement très dur je
tentais de récupérer en permanence afin
de vivre pleinement et surtout de
travailler vous pouvez vraiment vous
transformés en cyborg
si vous voulez mais très peu pour moi
allez viens ici viens viens ici le jeune
tigre est venue de là il semble que oui
c'est là que le chien effrayé il avait à
peu près la taille d'un chien non un peu
plus gros et le chien s'est jeté sur lui
oui oui c'est un très bon chien on le
surveille ce jeune tigre
on a trouvé sa mère on avait vraiment
peur qu'ils soient orphelins ils à
flâner devant les caméras pendant 40
minutes
puis il est allé en bas vers la maison
vers les gars il est venu à la porte
intéressant d'accord c'était intéressant
de le regarder à l'écran pour ce qui est
des tigres il est plus intéressant de
les voir à la télé je peux vous
l'assurer
voilà je suis sorti chercher du lait je
les lui assis là bas mais dites moi il
ya eu deux histoires ici avec des tigres
l'année dernier un tigre a tué une vache
sachez qu'il existe un programme pour
compenser ces pertes mais pour cela vous
devez suivre certaines instructions il
sera nécessaire de mesurer les
empreintes de ses pattes
pavel enseigne aux agriculteurs comment
se protéger et protéger leur bétail des
tigres sans risque et sans enfreindre la
loi sans tuer un animal en voie de
disparition
merci beaucoup merci à vous au revoir au
revoir
bon
[Musique]
là j'ai besoin de mettre des gouttes
malheureusement j'ai été hors service
pendant presque un an depuis peu de
temps je me sens un peu mieux mais avant
honnêtement j'étais vraiment mal
non
il
[Musique]
bon
m
cette odeur à ramat
ce conteneur est rempli de cadavres
d'animaux sauvages tués par des
braconniers ces cadavres seront envoyés
aux centres de diagnostic des maladies
des animaux sauvages dans la ville du
soliste afin d'effectuer des examens
biologiques médico-légaux spécifiques
il se peut qu'ils arrivent ici jusqu'à
10 tigres
il y en a 500 80 au total il y à 25 ans
pavel a commencé à travailler sur les
tigres
la situation était catastrophique ce
centre a été créé avec l'aide du wwf
pour aider les autorités à interrompre
le trafic d'espèces sauvages vers la
chine mais il n'a pas été possible
d'éliminer complètement le braconnage
très souvent nous recevons des produits
qui peuvent être vendus très chers en
particulier dans la région asie
pacifique
notre tâche consiste à déterminer
comment cet animal a été tué nous devons
comprendre qui a fait ça comment cela a
eu lieu un animal mort nous en raconte
plus qu'un animal vivant
belle bête je crois que c'est une junkie
grèce qui vient de mettre au monde sa
progéniture l'orne
je ne sais pas combien les étés mais
elle a eu des bébés tigres c'est certain
mais celle qui l'attaqué était
probablement un peu plus grande oui elle
était plus grande proches aussi étrange
que cela puisse paraître les alliés de
pavel dans la lutte contre le braconnage
la contrebande et l'abattage illégal
sont les réserves de chasse
je vois qu'ils se sont lâchés sur la
copie s'il sasha c'est ce qui s'est
passé ici c'est la plaine inondable de
la rivière signer gorka la première
partie de la forêt est une zone spéciale
de protection des eaux
elle a probablement été choisi pour des
coupes sélectives on voit ici par
exemple un vieux fresne n'ayant aucune
valeur économique c'est du bois de
chauffage il devait être coupé en
premier mais il reste ils ont aussi
laissé un sapin tout sec
un autre freine dont la sim est morte il
est toujours là et puis il ya la souche
d'un jeune freine parfaitement 5 qui a
été coupée y en a beaucoup
oui il y en a trop et vote à tain et
d'après attend maintenant des violations
il y en a à la pelle
le problème en fait est que ça va
devenir une zone morte
les animaux qui vivent dans cette forêt
sont les plus vulnérables face à une
telle situation
les lois doivent être adaptées vannes
d'après nos estimations cette tigres
vivent dans le massif de signer gorille
s'étend il n'y en avait aucun le nombre
d'onglets a considérablement augmenté
ici le braconnage a pratiquement été
éliminés donc les tigres sont arrivés
dans la forêt
je crois que c'est un blaireau oui oui
un blaireau ah le voilà le tigre a le
voilà comme il est beau à mal quand on
voit un animal de ses propres yeux
en vrai on peut évaluer ces paramètres
ses problèmes ses blessures
chaque tigre a son propre motifs ses
propres rayures c'est unique
c'est un peu comme des empreintes
digitales vous voyez si les empreintes
de pattes sont dans la même taille grâce
aux rayures on sait combien de tigre on
a ici
[Musique]
c'est un ours qui est déjà sorti de sa
tanière ils en sortent affamés et
ensuite ils se mettront a dévasté leur
mangeoire rouge que vous voyez par ce
temps là ça devrait être gelé au sol
cela signifie que comme disent les
chasseurs les traces sont encore chaudes
regardez cette grande foulée qu'il a
c'est un monstre un ours brun j'ai en
tout près de nous c'est un bon endroit
pour les bêtes sauvages aller mieux vaut
partir d'ici allez faut vraiment y aller
maintenant
[Musique]
ans
eh bien on charge le fusil c'est pavel
qui va tirer je pense oui
les médecins doivent l'examiner d'abord
et nous signaler que nous pouvons
commencer on va le peser et l'amener ici
personne ne doit entrer pendant que
l'anesthésiste l'un tube une fois qu'il
est sous anesthésie
on peut travailler nous pensons que cet
animal a été heurté par une voiture
[Musique]
il est fort probable qu'après cela il a
eu d'autres mésaventures
[Musique]
il a sûrement dû être attaqué par un
autre là au bar à en juger les blessures
et morsures que nous avons pu examiner
[Musique]
c'est sa cinquième anesthésie il faut à
nouveau ouvrir et traiter la plaie à
l'omoplate
puis faire une radiographie et vérifier
si le radius s'est bien remis en place
le traitement et l'entretien de la bête
sont prises en charge par l'organisation
à but non lucratif léopard d'extrême
orient
le travail des gardes-chasse de primorié
est formidable nous sommes immédiatement
arrivées sur place et avons attrapé cet
animal les spécialistes du centre de
réhabilitation d'alexei f cas où nous
sommes on fait un très bon boulot et
grâce aux éminents médecins de la
clinique vétérinaire nika nous avons la
possibilité d'effectuer des opérations
et de traiter cette bête aux autres
c'est aussi relativement frais oui on a
eu des progrès tangibles en dix jours
combien de kilos at il pris 5 kg assez
bien même son pelage a repris de l'éclat
oui il est redevenu plus brillants ici
la turgescence est bonne et là on voit
il ya un peu plus de graisses ici
heureusement l'animal s'est avéré être
un vrai gaillard il est clair que sans
l'aide de l'homme cette bête serait mars
ce léopard a de la chance
non seulement il a survécu mais il peut
aussi espérer être relâchés dans la
nature en extrême orient le moindre
léopard compte il en reste seulement une
centaine sur la planète
quel gros progrès peut-être que je
croise les doigts
si on réussit les gars
ce sera une victoire
on peut louer une grande victoire
pourquoi
les gros clients à emporter
nous voyons que le processus suit son
cours je suis vraiment jaloux de cette
incroyable capacité de régénération
mais pour ça il faut vivre longtemps
dans la taïga à l'état sauvage comme je
veux être libre
pourquoi je ne suis pas un faucon
pourquoi je ne sais pas volé
[Musique]
bbbb
le faucon sacre est une espèce en voie
d'extinction en raison du braconnage
il est très prisé par les pays arabes
qui ont une vieille tradition de
fauconnerie l'ornithologue igor kayak in
se bat depuis plusieurs années pour la
préservation de la population de cette
espèce rare chez les arabes
il ya un mythe selon lequel le faucon
sauvage est le meilleur mais c'est un
mythe
nous le voyons à la façon dont les
oiseaux du centre d'élevage s'intègre
dans la population sauvage ils n'ont
rien à envier à un oiseau sauvage mais
ce mythe est maintenue dans les pays
arabes
puis et beaucoup sont prêts à payer plus
cher pour un oiseau sauvage que pour un
faucon d'élevage parce qu'ils croient
dur comme fer qu'il est meilleur
[Musique]
et voici un nouveau participant à
l'expérience unique du wwf pour la
conservation du faux consacrant russie
veut laisse-moi récupérer et laisse-moi
bonne fille la femelle ne connais pas
ces petits et s'inquiètent parce qu'on
lui enlève ses yeux pour les placer dans
un incubateur
mais bientôt l'instinct maternel
s'éveille 1 et maintenant ces oisillons
qui ont visiblement grandi ont atteint
le sud de la sibérie où les
ornithologues cherche des familles
sauvage pour les placer
[Musique]
il y a deux groupes disent oiseaux
viennent de moscou fpt
ils ont été élevés à noizay le v8
aspects et 10 viennent de barnaoul de
l'oisellerie altaï falcone oh mon dieu
il est sauvage 7 heures se sont écoulées
depuis qu'on les a nourris non les
oisillons est élevé pour être relâchés
dans la nature ils ont été nourris par
leurs parents à temps arrête arrête dis
donc
étant donné que 90% des oisillons élevé
en pleine nature sont capturés par des
gens c'est là une très faible
compensation comme ça la haute vallée
comme celui là il n'a plus faim oui
celui ci est prêt à encore qui mord soit
celui-là recueillons
ce projet consiste avant tout à
restaurer le patrimoine génétique que
l'homme a déjà retiré à cette population
de rapaces
[Musique]
après la naissance de leur fille la
famille d'ornithologues corps yakine
nickolenko a dû revoir son mode de vie
ils leur pensée et ont décidé de ne rien
changer
à présent toute la famille prend part
aux expéditions et il ne passe dans leur
maison de novossibirsk que quelques mois
par an elle vira nickolenko emmène des
oiseaux dans les steppes de la sibérie
méridionale où son mari igor kayak in
inspectent minutieusement les nids qui
pourront accueillir les petits
moins chers amis nous avons fait le tour
du territoire et examiner quatre nippons
il ya quelque chose là-bas semble-t-il
oui il ya quelque chose dans l'un de ces
nids il ya des oisillons recouvert d'un
duvet il y en a beaucoup dans notre nid
ils sont cinq
leurs parents pourront à peine les
nourrir
nous sommes maintenant descendu du nid
la couvée a été détruite par un grand
rapace probablement par un grand duc
leur reste se trouve peut-être dans des
niches quelque part au dessus du ni nous
ni déposeront pas les petits carrés
seront également manger nous allons
chercher d'autres ni pour y placer les
oisillons d'audace enfin l'équipe
d'ornithologues et de bénévoles est au
complet
ils n'ont que quelques jours pour
installer tous les oisillons
une tâche qui est loin d'être aisé à
part je t'aime je t'aime aussi on peut
aller plus vite mais il faut garder la
même distance sinon j'accélère et je
vous laisse derrière ne soyez pas en
retard
amélioration des compétences du cortège
présidentiel
on met un peu les ghazal et je pleure
pas chérie nous va te mettre une petite
capture chute
alors elle a peut-être mal
il a peur ils résistent beaucoup
qu'est-ce-qu'il gigote moi aussi j'ai
peur il pourrait y laisser des plumes ne
lui casse pas la pâte y résistent
[Musique]
s'il te plaît arrête de lutter c'est un
traceur jan pour évaluer notre effort
nous devons connaître le sort de chaque
oiseau faut donc en russie et même au
pakistan
on a réussi à faire sa grâce au signal
des balises alors nous avons mesuré les
oiseaux et mis les balises la voix s'y
attacher pink et nous mettons l'oiseau
dans le nombre à bhl et si on parle de
la capture des faucons ce sont bien sûr
des professionnels sont principalement
originaires de syrie - souvent d'irak et
de libye et d'autres pays où ils ont
fait ça toute leur vie à l'époque 25000
faucon niché sur le territoire allant de
la banlieue de moscou jusqu'à la taille
immigrés vers leur pays pour y passer
l'hiver quand toutes ces populations
étaient éradiquées
les chasseurs se sont précipités ici on
a déjà arrêté un groupe de 12 personnes
à kaka si ils étaient tous syrien c'est
bien sûr locaux y participent mais par
rapport à ce qu un syrien gagne sur les
faucons ce qu'il paie aux locaux est
vraiment ridicule
l'élevage du bétail rapporte bien plus
bien plus que la capture illégale de
faucons mais malheureusement tout dépend
de la mentalité des gens bien trou ne va
pas dans le trou à temps
nos héros sont obligés de dresser leur
corps en pleine nuit il en sera de même
chaque jour jusqu'à ce que tous les
faucons soient relâchés dans la nature
papa et ma maman vont paris et dans la
lignée groupe monier de pour mesurer des
pâtes et pour mesurer le bec des
oisillons
n'empêche que c'est quelquefois mon père
il arrache seul crime est là mais dans
l'alcool est ce pour faire un petit test
[Musique]
important oignons s'il te plaît j'arrive
maman
[Musique]
merci oui voilà ce qui fait d'attentes à
issia tiens ramène ça sur la table
[Musique]
fais attention
et un an de papa il est ainsi tout le
temps à l'ordinateur et passe ses
journées comme ça crée ces rapports ne
sait jamais à quoi s'attendre avec cet
oiseau c'est absolument imprévisible
pourquoi il faut avoir du flair il faut
sentir où il faut tourner et à quel
moment pour trouver un bon endroit
ici les premières années cantal c'est
n'était pas encore là et que en plus je
n'étais pas au volant j'étais plein
d'énergie je dansais sur ces montagnes
sur ces pierres parce que j'avais de la
force ces derniers temps on évite des
ennuis a et c est à bord vous n'imaginez
pas ce que ça implique comme discipline
j'ai aussi une règle immuable dans la
nuit on ne roule pas on ne cherche pas
un site ou dresser le campement surtout
dans les zones marécageuses
[Musique]
nos ornithologues s'empresse de déposer
les oisillons avant qu'il ne soit
totalement couverts de plumes un bientôt
l'instinct les fera s'envoler pour
l'heure cet instinct l'ordi de se cacher
du milan même si le voit pour la
première fois
les principaux consommateurs sont les
émirats arabes unis le qatar et l'arabie
saoudite
il y assez de loi la cites donc c'est à
dire que le commerce est interdit
ils ont fait du lobbying au niveau
international pour que la mongolie leur
wendel également défaut quant aux moines
mais les faucons de mongolie ne les
intéresse pas une capture les nôtres
lors des migrations les nôtres migrent
tout à travers la mongolie
on a pris les oisillons pour les bagues
et leur faire des prélèvements pour une
analyse les mesurer après quoi on va les
déposer dans un nid avec les petits
élevé dans notre centre le nid sera
élargi pour qu'il ne tombe pas ils sont
tous manoury il est trop maigre
les fauconniers arabes ont une tradition
après une saison de chasse les oiseaux
sont relâchés mais ce n'est pas aussi
simple
ils prennent par exemple un oiseau ils
chassent pour un chèque son psychisme
est perturbé il est toujours affamé
ricard un oiseau bien nourris ne chasse
pas bien une très grande chaleur ils
sont simplement relâché c'est tout
90 % de ces oiseaux meurent ils ne
peuvent pas survoler la mer parce qu'ils
ne savent tout simplement pas ce qu'est
la mer la réparation du nid est terminée
les ornithologues
ils remettent les oisillons tellement
agité qu'ils ne font pas attention au ni
ni au fait qu'ils soient plus nombreux
les parents sauvage acceptent
généralement les nouveaux bébés ou
peut-être ne s'agit-il tout simplement
pas compter
c'est votre frère ou que tu siffles les
billets une soeur je vois je il ne faut
pas insulter les femmes
[Rires]
[Musique]
bon c'est fini on met un dernier hamster
dans ce nid pour les nourrir ce sont les
dernière couvée que nous avons complété
avec des oisillons sur ce territoire
charr maintenant nous irons dans les
montagnes espérons que nous osons iront
bien malgré toute son expérience
igor s'inquiète tellement pour les
faucons qu'ils en oublient de se soucier
de sa propre sécurité
le soleil estival a réveillé des tic une
attaque de tic
j'en ai enlevé 20 mais regarde là je n'y
en a encore tellement tu as dû les
attraper sur un arbre non à l'instant
lorsque tu étais debout près de moi tout
ça tout à l'heure ce n'est que la moitié
le reste je disais déjà enlevé à temps
si tu enlève ton t-shirt tu vas en avoir
partout
si tu en avais dans les cheveux tu le
saurais et je pensais qu'il y en avait
une dizaine lève les bras ne bouge pas
c'est une vraie attaque une dizaine il
disait une dizaine
[Musique]
à
en 1989 j'ai été mordu par une tique
encéphalique ma première encéphalite à
ça a été assez dur j'avais de la fièvre
des maux de tête
[Musique]
cela m'est arrivé au cours d'une
expédition 20 ans plus tard nouvelles
encéphalites
[Musique]
et après ça mon immunité s'est dégradée
on peut dire que j'ai une encéphalite un
borréliose et une fièvre hémorragique
voici trois maladies professionnelles de
gens qui passent beaucoup de temps dans
la forêt et qui sont souvent en contact
avec des animaux dans notre trousse de
premiers soins il ya toujours un
éventail de médicaments nécessaires
contre la peste le choléra la tulle et
rami la fièvre hémorragique et
l'encéphalite on a tout ce qu'il faut
tout le monde n'est pas aussi chanceux
que lui là où il a attrapé c'est
terrible maladie il n'était pas seul
quand je m'enlève dytique il en a
presque 100
par là c'est facile de grimper igor tu
vois comment
bah oui comment es-tu monté par la
gauche cherche moins on s'est approché
du nid le plus productif fasse un moment
en boucle ici un couple de faucons a
toujours cinq heures fait qu'ils sont
sains et comme c'est le territoire le
plus mauvais pour ce qui est des
réserves en nourriture
le taux de survie est toujours faible le
nid se trouve sur cette galerie nous ne
pouvons mais pas voir ce qu'il y a
combien d'oisillons il y as quel âge ils
ont je veux rapporté le poussin et 1,9
et probablement pas fécondé
j'ai sauvé un poussin ses deux frères
aînés l'ont poussé hors du nil tombé
n'était pas nourri par ses parents
l'année dernière on a déposé des
auzilhon dans ce nid où il y avait déjà
un coussin sauvage
oui vont me referais tu m'a pas donné la
pince qui va contrôler si ce n'est pas
toi toi bien sûr et bien je ne vais pas
je les mises dans mon sac cherche bien
là bas j'y arrive j'ai trouvé c'est quoi
tout ça c'est juste le foutoir
et au moins le talkie walkie marche oui
[Musique]
l'oiseau a un fort tempérament
malheureusement c'est précisément ce qui
intéresse les braconniers comme sur
agressif petit
[Musique]
je
eq allons nous donner à manger aux
faucons tassia du concombre ne mange pas
de concombres mais si toi tu manges pas
de concombres
alors qui papa va attraper une souris
jimena salade
j'en ai apporté un peu plus pour tout le
monde la fin juillet vif plein d'énergie
ne s'agit pas de dénutrition n'y a pas
même le duvet il est tombé du nid il
n'ya pas longtemps je te cherche donc je
pense qu'on va le nourrir aujourd'hui
dans le morceau est trop regarde sa
couche de graisse va commencer à se
restaurer le tissu musculaire doit se
renforcer
nous le relations dans un lit naturel de
faux consacre
[Musique]
nous avons mis en place un piège
photographique pendant une journée
les oisillons sont restés à l'écart de
celui que nous avons déposés puis sont
devenus amis et ils sont maintenant tous
ensemble notre mission est accomplie
les petits faux consacre que nous avons
élevé ont été relâchés dans des familles
sauvage le processus est en cours
notre surveillance vidéo a montré que
les pouces avait été acceptée les
paroles et nourrissent ya eu deux eaux à
gand 3 petits ont été emportées par le
vent mais ils sont revenus au nid il ya
une chance qu'on voit un jour ne faut
qu'on relâche et se reproduire et qu'ils
ne sont pas tous capturé par des
braconniers
quand chaque personne n'a été blessé
dans sa chair et dans son âme mais nous
en fichons à la nature des blessures
beaucoup plus profonde est terrible est
ce que la nature pour anno pardonner je
ne sais pas
peut-être que d'autres
[Musique]
il ya des lois ces lois sont bonnes en
principe la législation devrait
normalement assurer la conservation des
espèces rares mais il n'y a pas assez
d'enthousiastes
[Musique]
les mater et pure et innocente timide
comme une fille
ici les lacs sont bleu dans le ciel se
réflète
les rivières les montagnes on regarde
les maires
mater
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]